antes de que empecemos a describir lo
que son los accidentes cerebrovasculares
vamos primero a orientarnos para que
podamos ver toda esta imagen de forma
adecuada así que esta es una perspectiva
lateral de una persona y aquí digamos
está el contenido de lo que hay dentro
del cráneo muy bien así que vamos a
etiquetar algunas cosas justamente aquí
tenemos lo que es el cráneo eso es el
cráneo y obviamente el cráneo protege el
cerebro verdad esto es el cerebro que
tenemos en color rosa aquí abajo tenemos
el cerebelo esto será el cerebelo y este
es el tronco el tronco cerebral también
se le conoce a veces como tallo cerebral
muy bien este es el tronco cerebral
ahora en términos de vasos sanguíneos
muy bien las azules que tenemos aquí son
venas las azules son justamente venas y
estas venas son las que se encargan de
drenar el cerebro
ahora vamos a etiquetar algunas arterias
al frente tenemos la arteria carótida
interna muy bien esta es la arteria
cargo
interna y como recordemos que estamos
viendo a esta persona del lado por
supuesto esta será la del lado izquierdo
ahora la que podemos observar que va
como ocurriendo dentro de las vértebras
es la arteria vertebral
esta es la arteria vertebral
y luego podemos ver que se pone un
poquito más complicado esta es la
arteria vacilar esta que se encuentra
aquí es la arteria cerebral media que
simplemente vamos a llamarle hace m de
este lado tenemos la arteria cerebral
posterior que vamos a denotar como acp y
en el frente tenemos la arteria cerebral
anterior muy bien que vamos a escribir
como sea y ahora podemos ver cómo está
esta parte que se le conoce como el
círculo de willis es el círculo de
willis muy bien ahora centrémonos en el
tema
todos estos vasos sanguíneos de los que
hemos estado hablando son los que
proporcionan el suministro de sangre al
cerebro muy bien son los que
cerebro y por supuesto puede ser que
hagan un suministro algunas partes del
cerebro o a todo el cerebro muy bien
entonces cuando este suministro de
sangre ya no
existe por alguna razón entonces el
cerebro empieza a perder algunas de sus
funciones y es aquí cuando decimos que
tenemos un accidente cerebrovascular muy
bien y esencialmente hay dos razones
principales por las cuales puede haber
uno de estos accidentes la primera de
ellas es cuando tenemos una obstrucción
del flujo sanguíneo muy bien y déjame
hacer un dibujo para hacer mucho más
claro de lo que es la obstrucción del
flujo sanguíneo muy bien entonces
digamos que por alguna razón está siendo
bloqueada la arteria cerebral anterior
muy bien y eso significa que la sangre
que va digamos en esta dirección de este
lado de dicha arteria no puede atravesar
al otro lado de la arteria cerebral muy
bien y si dicha sangre no puede
atravesar hacia el otro lado entonces el
tejido cerebral que depende de esa
sangre para sus necesidades de oxígeno
comenzará a lastimarse y eventualmente
tendrá que morir el segundo tipo de
ataque que digamos es no es tan común
pero es muy muy peligroso es cuando
tenemos una
una ruptura de algún vaso sanguíneo y
cuando uno de estos vasos se rompe
digamos pensemos por ejemplo aquí en la
arteria cerebral anterior aquí tenemos
un pedacito de la unión que hay con la
arteria comunicante anterior y digamos
que empieza a bombear en un pedacito
entonces en realidad estamos diciendo
que se está formando un aneurisma y ese
aneurisma eventualmente puede romperse
muy bien si se rompe el aneurisma
entonces empezará a sangrar digamos en
esta parte que no corresponde a la
circulación cerebral y empezará a llenar
todo este espacio de sangre si esto
ocurre tenemos principalmente dos
consecuencias la primera es que como
estamos volteando sangre hacia esta zona
verdad no estamos liberando sangre fuera
de la circulación cerebral entonces
estas partes digamos que dependen de la
arteria que estamos considerando que en
este caso es nuestra acea
obviamente no estarán recibiendo nada de
sangre así que nuevamente el tejido
comenzará a lastimarse
esta parte verdad por otro lado la
sangre comenzará a juntarse en esta en
este lado y eso va a provocar que el
cerebro se ha empujado digamos como en
esta dirección y esa es otra forma en la
que puede lastimarse el cerebro que y
entonces esencialmente esos son los dos
tipos de accidentes cerebrovasculares
cuando sólo digamos estás haciendo un
bloqueo del flujo sanguíneo a cierta
área entonces a ese también se le conoce
como accidente cerebrovascular isquémico
muy bien en este caso estamos hablando
de un accidente isquémico isquémico se
refiere a un ambiente un ambiente
celular en donde no hay suficiente
oxígeno y cuando estamos hablando de
cuando se rompe un vaso sanguíneo como
vimos anteriormente a ese se le conoce
como un accidente hemorrágico muy bien
en este caso estaremos hablando de un
accidente hemorrágico y hemorrágico se
refiere justamente como a una
a salida repentina y torrencial de
sangre muy bien pero independientemente
de cual estemos hablando ok digamos en
ambos casos en ambos casos las células
cerebral las células cerebrales dejan de
funcionar muy bien las células
cerebrales dejan de funcionar después de
alrededor de digamos tres minutos
ok dejan de funcionar después de tres
minutos y esencialmente esto es por dos
razones la primera de ellas es por una
falta de oxígeno o2 y la segunda de
ellas es por falta de glucosa falta de
glucosa muy bien y por supuesto se
necesita la glucosa en la sangre para
funcionar de forma adecuada y llevar
digamos a cabo todas estas funciones
complicadas ahora qué pensarías tú si
una parte del cerebro simplemente deja
de trabajar o empieza a funcionar de
forma inadecuada bueno intuitivamente
podrías pensar bueno si una parte del
cerebro empieza a funcionar mal entonces
podría perder ciertas habilidades verdad
habilidades que esa parte del cerebro de
desarrollar cierto así que veamos
algunos ejemplos aquí así que digamos
que tenemos un gran coágulo que se
encuentra justo aquí a la mitad de la
arteria media cerebral entonces como
hemos discutido la sangre ya no va a
poder circular al resto de las zonas en
donde estaban siendo irrigadas
anteriormente verdad eso es lo que va a
provocar es que todas estas zonas que
mencionamos todas estas zonas que
estaban siendo irrigadas anteriormente
por la arteria media cerebral dejan de
funcionar de forma adecuada verdad y
esencialmente hay dos partes muy
importantes dos zonas muy importantes
del cerebro que se encuentran aquí
justamente la primera de ellas es el
área de broca muy bien es el área de
broca y la segunda de ellas es el área
de wernicky
bien estas dos se encargan de producir
el habla esencialmente determinan cómo
es que hablamos y si podemos o no
entender lo que las otras personas nos
dicen así que si tenemos un gran coágulo
a la mitad de la arteria cerebral media
y de repente detenemos el flujo de
sangre de hacia el área de broca o hacia
el área de wernicky entonces vamos a
tener problemas de habla hagamos otro
ejemplo digamos que tenemos un nuevo
coágulo en esta pequeña arteria que está
saliendo de la arteria habacilar muy
bien está por supuesto alcanza algunos
de los nervios que se encuentran en el
tronco cerebral muy bien en este en
estas y en esta pequeña zona aquí hay un
montón de pequeños nervios muy
especiales que se les conocen como
nervios craneales que se originan en el
tronco cerebral muy bien y digamos que
se van en caminos separados desde ahí y
de alguna forma están involucrados en
controlar los músculos faciales así que
si estos nervios pierden digamos oxígeno
entonces esperaríamos ver que nuestra
boca digamos como que se cae verdad y lo
mismo ocurriría con nuestros
párpados básicamente no seríamos capaces
de usar algunos músculos de nuestra cara
ahora bien uno se preguntaría
exactamente qué es lo que determina que
tan malo o qué tan peligroso puede ser
un ataque cerebrovascular y en realidad
hay dos cosas que considerar cuando por
ejemplo el lugar en el cerebro en donde
ocurre y qué tanto tejido cerebral se
está dañando muy bien y que es lo que
determina eso bueno eso está determinado
por el tipo de vasos sanguíneos que
están involucrados por ejemplo si
tenemos un coágulo justo por acá
entonces lo que va a ocurrir como ya
hemos dicho es que la sangre ya no va a
irrigar sin embargo aquí está muy
comprometido todo lo que es el tronco o
el tallo cerebral y eso es eso sería muy
muy malo porque entonces el tronco
cerebral empezaría a morirse y en
realidad el tronco cerebral es
responsable para mantenernos vivos el
tronco cerebral tiene centros de
regulación que controlan la respiración
y el corazón y muchas otras funciones
vitales
en contraste por ejemplo si tuviéramos
un pequeño coágulo aquí o un pequeño
coágulo aquí o un pequeño coágulo acá en
este tipo de vasos pequeños en realidad
el daño cerebral con el que
terminaríamos sería sumamente pequeño
verdad
en realidad sería pequeño porque las
áreas lastimadas digamos de cada uno de
estos son relacionados con cada uno de
estos coágulos en realidad sería muy
pequeño así que el tipo de lista de
discapacidad funcional que podríamos
sufrir después de este tipo de ataques
comparados por ejemplo con el que
teníamos aquí que sería muy muy grande
verdad
en realidad habría una gran diferencia
entre los tipos de discapacidad
funcionales que tendríamos verdad y en
realidad todo esto depende de dónde se
origina digamos el ataque
cerebrovascular y que tanta área del
cerebro está involucrada ahora la
pregunta es este este daño cerebral es
irreversible y desafortunadamente la
mayoría de las ocasiones así es las
neuronas en ausencia de oxígeno y
glucosa empiezan a morir aproximadamente
cuatro minutos después de que se quedan
sin oxígeno ahora bien que podría causar
un accidente cerebrovascular
para que ocurra bueno esencialmente hay
algunas condiciones del corazón que son
factores muy importantes para que se
pueda generar un ataque cerebrovascular
por ejemplo uno de ellos es la
fibrilación atrial muy bien la
fibrilación atrial y esencialmente
consiste cuando algunas de las cámaras
superiores del corazón dejan de
contraerse de forma adecuada y eso
genera digamos coágulos de sangre que
después pueden ser bombeados desde el
corazón hacia el cerebro y por supuesto
pueden atorarse en nuestros vasos
sanguíneos cerebrales como vimos
anteriormente otra digamos causa
relacionada con el corazón es el infarto
del miocardio o bien lo que conocemos
como un ataque al corazón y esto con si
consiste cuando las paredes del corazón
dejan de contraerse de forma adecuada y
cuando eso ocurre algunos pequeños
digamos coágulos de sangre pueden crecer
en la
paredes del corazón y después ser
bombeados hacia el cerebro ahora bien
otra causa muy común quizás es la más
común de todas las que causan un ataque
cerebrovascular es cuando tenemos algo
conocido como arteriosclerosis muy bien
y esencialmente son placas de colesterol
son placas de colesterol colesterol que
se acumulan en las paredes de los vasos
sanguíneos muy bien entonces esto se le
conoce como placa aterosclerótica
arteriosclerótica muy bien esencialmente
son cúmulos de colesterol que por
ejemplo en este caso se hayan acumulado
en la carótida interna y que como puedes
imaginar es que le dificultan mucho al
flujo sanguíneo atravesar por éste por
esta arteria cierto entonces tendrá un
man un momento muy complicado para pasar
a través de esta placa de colesterol y
eso esencialmente es la arterosclerosis
muy bien y esto por supuesto puede
ocurrir en distintas partes del cerebro
por ejemplo si ya tenemos una y podría
ser que tengamos otro
a otra placa de colesterol acá otra
placa ateroesclerótica aquí puede ser
que tengamos otra por acá también muy
bien así que en realidad estos son muy
muy peligrosos son las placas
ateroscleróticas ahora bien déjenme
cambiar brevemente de tema vamos a
hablar sobre los ataques isquémicos
transitorios que por sus siglas siglas
en inglés se les llama tías pero aquí
las siglas serían ahí t muy bien también
son conocidos como mini ataques y un ay
t esencialmente es una interrupción es
una interrupción temporal del flujo
sanguíneo hacia hacia ciertas partes del
cerebro verdad y los síntomas y los
síntomas son muy similares a los ataques
cerebrovasculares síntomas son similares
los ataques cerebrovasculares pero
digamos que la gran diferencia es que
los aires no causan muerte cerebral que
no causan digamos muerte cerebral o
muerte de las células cerebrales verdad
y por eso es que no causan una
discapacidad permanente muy bien de
hecho una de las grandes diferencias es
que estos digamos los síntomas no duran
más de 24 horas verdad digamos que
después de 24 horas ha desaparecido por
completo verdad mientras que si
tuviéramos un ataque cerebrovascular
propiamente no no recuperaríamos
nuestras funciones normales de nuevo
hasta después de semanas meses o quizás
nunca lo recuperemos por el resto de
nuestra vida verdad así que déjame
mostrarte rápidamente cómo es que se ve
esto en un en un ataque cerebrovascular
propiamente dicho
tenemos digamos un coágulo aquí que
causa la muerte de verdad la muerte de
las de las neuronas alrededor de esta
zona en cambio cuando tenemos un
y digamos sólo tenemos un coágulo de la
misma forma que antes que también
empieza a generar daño alrededor del
cerebro pero inmediatamente lo que
ocurre es que ese coágulo empieza a
desaparecer muy bien ese coágulo empieza
a desaparecer y con él empieza a
desaparecer también todo el daño verdad
simplemente comienza a recuperarse ahora
para terminar solo quiero aclarar
algunos conceptos erróneos sobre los
ataques cerebrovasculares y hay como un
pensamiento común de que están solo
relacionados con problemas cardíacos
verdad problemas del corazón sin embargo
sabemos que esos solo son algunos
ejemplos de causas que generan ataques
cerebrovasculares en un estricto sentido
los ataques cerebrovasculares son
condiciones relacionadas a una falta de
suministro de flujo sanguíneo en
realidad es un problema del cerebro muy
bien hay otro concepto erróneo que dice
que esto sólo es un problema de viejos
verdad sólo se presenta en viejos y
aunque es cierto que dos terceras partes
del
ataques cerebrovasculares ocurren en
personas mayores de 65 años todavía hay
una tercera parte que tiene ataques por
debajo de los 65 años así que estos
ataques pueden ocurrir en personas a
distintas edades y el último hay una
idea de que los ataques no se pueden
prevenir no se pueden prevenir y esto es
completamente erróneo muy bien hay
muchas cosas que se pueden hacer para
evitar tener un ataque cerebrovascular
por ejemplo controlando la presión
sanguínea o dejando de fumar